à la recherche de la vérité est qu en
outre cette réputation mais oblige
souvent à me conduire en faible roulant
11 b 4e mois moi je peux pas me
prononcer rires j'aimerais qu'on prenne
au sérieux et je vous raconte des choses
que vous empêchera de me prendre au
sérieux
peut-être parce que je voudrais à je
veux être sincère nous acteurs nous
sommes des mensonges
puisque nous cherchons toujours à être
un autre mais le mensonge que nous
sommes recherche la vérité
mes premières armes me donner à
réfléchir à ce sujet j'avais obtenu une
audition conservatoire mobel je vais
travailler un monologue de chatterton
d'alfred de vigny et je donnais cette
scène à monsieur d'orival dès les
premiers mots je fus emporté dans un
autre univers
j'éprouve une jouissance extraordinaire
et on portait pas mon désordre je cru
être chatterton lui même
monsieur d'orival me laissa aller
jusqu'au bout puis il y eut un grand
silence jeu je revenais à la vie j'avais
du mal à quitter ce personnage j'avais
été totalement croyait soudain j'entends
dit une voix grave sonore timbre est
celle de monsieur de rêver je croyais
avoir été pour le moins sublime et cette
voie monsieur d'orival me dit vous êtes
malade mon petit ami
il faut allez vous faire soigner vous
êtes complètement hystérique tomber de
haut
malade l'était et même maladie était
celle du théâtre et je venais de la
contracter à ce moment même au
conservatoire modèle je mourrai de honte
et je n'ai jamais remis les pieds à ce
cours de théâtre
et pourtant monsieur d'orival m'avait
appris en une phrase tout le secret de
mon futur métier
il ne suffisait pas d'en jouir ni de se
laisser aller dans des personnages
il fallait devenir 2 est à la fois le
diriger et le dirigeant retenir son
émotion sa sensibilité et la laisser
aller à d'autres moments s'observer à
tous les instants et pourtant laissé
libre sa spontanéité
n'est ce pas une situation fosse est
atroce que de se diriger jusqu'à la
jouissance est pourtant de s'empêcher
d'en jouir pour essayer de rester dans
la vérité est né ce part à un métier que
l'on peut aimer jusque-là gros plans 12
à troisième la belle et la bête est un
des films que je préfère